all the ingredients of a cost of living
crisis this center prepares meals for
those in need in wigan for more and more
people having to choose between eating
and heating even people who work here
struggling traveling in my shoes and see
what it's like
when your kids want things and you can't
get it um and you feel that
awful because you can't get on that
and you need other things besides what
your kids want like your food and your
bills keeping a roof over your head
i think that do your kids understand
yeah apart from the youngest 27 but
it's still warning
those on the front line see a situation
that's getting worse people are
frightened
people are actually saying that they're
threatened and
like our staff here um are saying oh
friend there if the bills coming through
the door i know they're going to make
ends meet and provide for the children
the local mp wants to know if the
chancellor is listening people simply
cannot keep their heads above water now
and there's worse to come so we need a
windfall tax on the oil and gas
producers to knock 200 pounds of
people's energy bills because people
need help right now but the government's
also got to think again about the
national insurance rise and the forced
council tax rise that is coming in in
just a few weeks time people just simply
can't afford it the question for many
with rishi sunax mini budget is whether
or not it matches the scale of the
challenge right now in places like this
one
but prices are going to continue to rise
for months if not years and the
chancellor has to decide whether or not
the government can step in each time to
help
rosia forecasts mean the chancellor has
almost 30 billion pounds more to spend
or save than at the time of last
autumn's budget senior tory back
ventures want him to spend it now should
he delay the national insurance rise by
a year i very much hope that he does
because i think this is uh not a good
move at this particular time either for
consumers and the lower paid to be
paying this extra tax but also for
businesses there'll be a great deal of
uncertainty in his mind as to exactly
where the economy is going to be head
once we get out of this initial
bounce-back phase of growth what's going
to happen beyond that so he will be
slightly cautious i think
yet another mini budget where the
chancellor is moving money around at the
last moment
more giveaways he didn't want to make a
month ago
does he think he can afford to stand by
people yet again
sam coates sky news westminster